he found love with Camila Elvis
McConaughey uh what advice would you
give to people on how to do just that
how to find love
[Laughter]
this wonderful subject's been discussed
since the beginning of time hadn't it
love it
um
so I can tell you what things I've kind
of learned and I'm still learning
you know
loves one of those mystical successes
it doesn't make sense
it
you know when I was when I was
before I met Camilla I had
I was coming onto my
late 30s as much as I'm not a person
that is Guided by timelines I was
my life had not really added up to what
I thought it was gonna be relationship
wise I thought about that time I would
have met the woman I loved married and
started family and that hadn't happened
and I did find myself
doing that thing I was doing at the
Amazon looking around the corner
any
perspective possible female I met that I
was attracted to I was like maybe this
is the one
I make the joke but it's true it's like
at every red light I'm like checking out
who's next to me in the produce section
at the supermarket on My Chosen produce
section you know it's like looking yeah
when you're in that zone
you can also be a little intrusive you
can trespass on people's you can get
outside of yourself you can be overly
impressed and not as involved and have
your own Constitution and sit back and
therefore
if you're outside yourself you're less
attractive
to your possible mate
I've got a series of
dreams that I've written about but I had
one then that was very spiritual that
was me as a radio your 88 year old
Bachelor who never got married and it
was a beautiful dream
we're on paper
I thought that should be a nightmare it
wasn't what that dream did for me was
allowed me to go
you may not
find the woman
for you
and get married
not a life with her that may not be
and for the first time in life I was
okay with that hmm
not more than intellectually spiritually
I was grounded I was like
okay
then I'm moving through the world and on
this particular night as myself not
intruding I was inviting I did see her
move across the room and did not say
who is that I said what is that
and then did
move to collar across the room so I did
invite but I was not outside of myself
and I was able to be myself
with her what my eyes saw
everything that she turned out to be
when
the lens got zoomed in more details got
known and we began to talk and got more
intimate and closer together and spend
more time became true and then some
but not every single thing that I
imagined when I saw her move across the
room turned out to be true and then so
in the just the image
um
we
found a had a moral similar moral bottom
line about life each other how we treat
ourselves what we respect what our own
Constitution to our we had similar
uh um
perspectives on raising children which
is very important
to me and her
and then we just enjoyed each other's
company yeah and we laughed together and
we support each other we promoted more
of each other and we lit each other's
fire
and we if one was rolling we kept
addition you go go go again take the
next shot more more and more
this was a biggie too
getting excited for each other's success
yes
to be able
think it's very important
we all have jealousy
I get it but it's very important to be
able
if you can
be happy for your lover when they
succeed
or are succeeding or are across the room
at the party laughing with a stranger
to be happy for them when it has nothing
to do with you
she was I would be away she would the
questions and the talks we would have
she was happy for me about how excited I
was about my day and my date had nothing
to do with her yeah yeah she was there
and I found myself not telling myself to
be happy for her but being really really
happy for her when she would tell me
about something that happened that day
with her and as much as I went through
my head oh I'd have been great if I
would have been there I was like no I'd
only trespass on that that you had that
yeah independent of me
Bravo
that that's a choice you make not to not
to give any time to the jealousy to the
very natural jealousy that we humans
have
it sure doesn't happening I don't see
the residuals in it
true I've got it I've had it and I have
it I just don't
you know I haven't seen where it has any
Payback